Hello everybody. This is Dr. Kevin Cutters. Welcome to another holistic health
hour. We're on the best to answer your questions. So if you have questions you
could chat, they've been here on this live call or you ever go to holistic
healthhour.com and you could ask questions through that. Better guarantee your
questions. Get on and you can see all our past episodes. We got a lot of them
now. And they're nicely archived with the indexes of what we're talking about.
So you could go to anything specific that you want to just, you know, you have
questions about. Also another gentle reminder to go to our website CuttersClinic.com
because on there we have well over a thousand blog posts nicely indexed. So if you
have a question about a robotizing inhibitor so you can find a really nice
article and probably an attached video where I've discussed that. We get
some suggestions. So you can find that all there on our YouTube channel. We'll go
to our videos. CuttersClinic.com channel. I don't know, 1200 videos. I don't know
what I'm counting. They're just so a lot of information. Okay let's jump into your
questions. Remember chatted questions if you could think of anything. First
question recently developed a recently developed a caper store of the soft
palette for the first time in my life. It did seem to correlate with stress but
since then I have to avoid coffee. Acidic fruits or it becomes irritated again.
Could this be indicating the deeper physiological issue or could it be just
diet related. So what are cacers or cold sores? What are they? They're herpes
virus. Some viruses are just nearly impossible to get rid of. They harbor in
ourselves. They harbor in our bodies. The oral herpes viruses harbor in the nerve
ganglia. The trigeminal ganglia on both sides and they live there until there's
an opportunity. And usually the opportunity is when we get a change of pH in our
mouth. So when our both drastically changes pH that gives an opportunity for
that virus to come down. What does that? Will you suck out a limit? I mean that's
a drastic acidic change in pH. Will you go under go stress? That's a change
that changes your pH. There's lots of different things that change your pH. Some
people will say I get my cold sores when this happens. It just you know all the
time I can tell and it goes around this time of the month or this time of the
year or when I do this or when I consume this and I regret it afterwards. So how can
you get rid of them? Elisid is a amino acid that has been proven to help with
cold sores. Taking a calcium lactate tablet, you can
calcium lactate, it's not any store and sucking on that has helped with some
people. Wedding a calcium lactate tablet and dabbing it on the cold sores has
helped some people. And then just be it aware to try to balance that pH of your
mouth where you're not eating acidic foods or something that you know this is
irritating them. How do you kill the virus so that it doesn't happen again? Well
sometimes you just can't. I wish I could say oh well you just have to do this take
these supplements or use the right machine that will knock it out every time. There
isn't just there's no proven way that you're gonna always kill this virus. If you
do have a right machine use the right on the Herby settings that has been
helpful for a lot of people too. If you don't have a right try those other
nutritional things and dietary things. It's a tough thing but once you have that
virus they tend to stay around a long time. They tend to be difficult to get rid
of and you just have to keep them at bay. Question came into the chat. What can
you do for loss of smell after a viral infection? So that has been a common
issue with the COVID viral infection. It's a common issue with a lot of different
viral infections. Some of the things that you could do to help improve that is there
are some supplements that can help stimulate neural growth if there's damage to
neurons themselves. But things that are going to decrease inflammation I think
are going to be your best thing. I would think of antihistamine type nutrition. We
have a product called clear histamine scavenger which covers a lot of the
histamine checkpoints because not just solely histamine that causes that
inflammation so that would be a good product to think about. It's difficult.
Vyruses are difficult to deal with because there's argument whether they're
truly living organisms or there's just a lot of argument and misdolage let's
say lack of knowledge that we have with viruses. A lot of things are hypotheses
about what a virus is and how they function and what they could do to our body.
Like I said with the Herpes virus seemingly it's people have tried everything and
they seemingly take a rid of them. All they do is knock you to tell them to keep
it in a bay and keep it in a state where it's not given an opportunity to flourish.
So they are difficult. That's where a lot of people use rife technology to
help with viruses and bacterial infection. We saw a big uptick in the purchase of
rife technology in this last quote unquote pandemic that we had because it was a
great tool to use to help keep your family healthy when there are you know thoughts
of different infections thoughts of different pandemics and possible loop
pandemics coming down the road. All right we're happy to write in your house can be
extremely beneficial. But again there is no magic cure and rife certainly isn't
a magic cure for any of these things either. So but I would certainly think frequency
technology is just another piece that you can add to the puzzle. Next question I'm
going through betapas and began having hot flashes a year ago. I had COVID approximately
one month ago and the hot flashes have worsened along with tea, brain pork,
decreased sense of taste and smell. Maybe some of you can share your regimen
regarding how you rebuild your system post COVID but also your regimen during
betapas. So having symptoms of hot flashes during betapas that's tackle that
first. So the reason why it works is that hot flashes during betapas and some
people go through betapas and don't have any betapasal symptoms. Why is that?
Because betapas is your ovary starting to shut down. Your ovaries are your
main source of production for progesterone and estrogen. However if you have
really healthy adrenal glands your adrenal glands will semi-makeup for the
loss of estrogen progesterone so that you could go through betapas without
having symptoms. So a person that has hot flashes a person that has to the
degree that they have symptoms during betapas really is a picture of the degree
of their ill health of their adrenal glands because betapas naturally is
going to be a decrease function of your ovaries. Again if you have really
healthy adrenal glands you could those are the people that sail through
betapas and say I went through betapas. Greatest thing in the world. I don't
have to deal with my monthly cycle anymore. Never had any symptoms. And other
women are like why do I have all these symptoms? And what's wrong with me? Well
what you'd be deployed to is what makes up for that loss of estrogen and
progesterone at least to smooth that out to a gradual point because even people
post-bentiposal will still have estrogen progesterone. Where is that coming
from? Even people that have had a hysterectomy still have estrogen and
progesterone. Where is that coming from? It's coming from the adrenal glands. So
the adrenal glands never will make a you know the same amount as the ovaries are
currently making pre-mediposal but they'll make enough to keep you from having
these symptoms. And the symptoms are these fluctuations in estrogen. That's
what causes the symptoms. And the adrenal glands should keep you healthy adrenal
glands to keep you from these fluctuations. Why does a person voice your
menopause? Heavy hot flashes and they got worse and a whole bunch of other
symptoms got worse when they had COVID? Well you could say you could say when
they had an infection, when they had a strap, when they had a high degree of
stress, when they went through you know a divorce, when they anything that's
going to put more stress on your adrenal glands is going to take away from
the adrenal glands ability to produce estrogen and progesterone for you to
smooth your way through menopause. So when you're having menopausal symptoms it's
really a function of your adrenal glands. So supporting adrenal glands should be
your first thought. How do you support the adrenal glands? How could you first
allow to take a step back? How could you measure adrenal gland function? There is
a test called it's a functional medicine test called adrenal stress test. It
measures cortisol through your cycle of a day. So you want to do this test on a
normal day, not on a heavy stress day, a day that you're under a dormous burden
mentally, but on a day that's going to be fairly normal. Maybe you'd say well
that's every day of my heavy burden day. Well that may be true. But you want to do it
at a fairly normal day. And it's the test will give you instructions. It is, you
are either doing salivary, usually it's a salivary sample at four different times
during the day. And you're marking it down, you're writing another test to what
this is at 8 a.m. This is at midnight. This is at, you know, due to this is at
3 o'clock. I think those are the typical times for a salivary adrenal stress
test. And you should see the cortisol levels. So that's measuring cortisol levels.
There's other tests that you could also get at the HEA level. Now I'd recommend
somebody going through these symptoms having metapausal issues is to do the
Dutch test. That's a dried urine hormone test for your hormones. And then it also
is testing. It's the Dutch plus I think. It's also testing the salivary cortisol levels.
Because then you'll get a picture of your adrenal function. And you'll get a
picture of your other hormones, the D-A-T-A, which is another hormone released by
the adrenal glands, which is a precursor to some progesterone and some of your
endrogens. And you'll get a measurement of your estrogens, progesterone, all
of the tablets thereof, and your endrogens. So it gives you a good picture of your
hormone levels and your cortisol level. So it gives you a good picture of your
adrenals and your ovaries, which can then give, you can discern the help of
your pituitary gland, which is the gland that stimulates all these things. So when a
person is, again, going through metapause, their lack of progesterone esteroid is
made up by the health of their adrenal glands. If that is compromised, they're
going to have metapausal symptoms. And then if they have an increased adrenal
stress from a virus or a bacterial infection, or a stressful event, or anything else
that can compromise the adrenal glands, you're going to have a worsening of those
symptoms. So addressing the health with the adrenal glands through testing it would
be one thing. And then from nutritional addressing the adrenal glands would be, by
taking supplements wise, it would be taking adaptogens. Not a big fan of taking
D-A-E-A. I typically only recommend D-A-E-A because it is a hormone. Whenever you
take a hormone, you're going to have a negative feedback loop for the hormone
production. So if you take D-A-E-A, you're basically telling your adrenal glands
that there's plenty of it. So it's basically shutting down the adrenals more. So I
typically only recommend D-A-E-A for a very short period of time. And it's only
when a person is an absolute complete adrenal exhaustive or fatigue. I'd rather
give adaptogens and supporting the adrenal gland functions through herbal adaptogens,
and building up the adrenals through adrenal tissue supplements. I think that's
a better way. Hopefully that answers your question. Next question. My husband has
been prescribed statins after his procedure with two heart stids. Which side
effects should he look out for while taking statins? Well, really you want to
look out for all your any possible side effects with taking any drugs and any
culture effects between drugs as well. So I always recommend people go to
Drugs.com and you can search your drug with your drug in and they have a free
search for side effects. I think that's a pretty good website. You could Google it
as well to look for the side effects and you should maybe print out the different
possible side effects of the drug that you have to take and then be looking out
for it. Their side effects because they have been proven to occur in people
taking the medication. So when drugs get approved they go through different
studies and in one of the phases of the study they have to have x amount of
people out the drug and they have to record any side effects that the person has
had. That's why when you watch these drug commercials and it might say even
early death because somebody died on the study and it could have been caused from
the drug. Maybe they've got a core of it. It's just they have to list it and there's
usually a lot of them. That's why they have some you know person that was
trained in auctioneer school to read that at the end of the commercial. So it is
something that you should look up and we become basically immune to all the
possible issues of different medications. And you know I think I don't know if I
shared last week or not but it's something as a practitioner that I have
failed sometimes because I don't take drugs. So I forget to ask people you know you
know to make that a pertinent question of oh you have this symptom what drug are
you taking if you looked up the side effects of that drug. I certainly don't have
all the side effects of different drugs but memorize. So I think it's easy
anything you can look up you should just do that. I'd go to drugs.com and look
those up. I don't know what particular ones that you should be looking for
you should use to look for anything that you possibly have. Also if you are taking
other medication they true you look those things up too. And if you can find any
drug interactions because I think drugs.com they also have drug interaction piece
of that search that I would search and look for that as well. Okay next question.
I have gamma MGUS recommendations to keep this stable. So gamma MGUS is a model
clonal gamma apathy which is like a it's not cancer but it can be a precursor to
multiple myeloma and other blood disorders. Similar to there's there's other
diseases probably sideopidia and other diseases and myeloblastic myeloblorific diseases
that are precursors to phoma precursors to leukemia precursors to multiple myeloma
the blood disorders the blood cancers. So how do you keep that at bay? How do you keep
that stable? Well there is no magic way to keep any of those things stable you're
just trying to clean up your diet, clean up anything that could be you know it's
just like any other um disease process or collection of symptoms that we call
syndromes. Whatever you're having you know health you want to be digging to
the reason why many times which you'll find in some of the core reasons why is
got help in inflammation. She did autoimmune diseases that you've never
knew you had. So doing some functional medicine tests can be helpful.
I said many many of our holistic health hours, many people will go in for a
annual physical and they'll get blood work done but nobody ever goes over their blood work.
And they're either that or they're told everything was in normal range but then they look at
their blood work and some things are outside of the normal range. Now I have a nice little video
that explains the difference between what normal lab ranges are and functional ranges. So there's
a difference between what is considered a normal range for a lab value and what is considered a normal
functional range for a lab value. You use white blood cells as an example. Normal lab range
on a white blood cell, every lab can have a different normal range. But typical normal lab ranges
in white blood cells typically like 4.0 to maybe 11. But functional normal functional
lab ranges should be like 4.5 to maybe 7.5. But if you're at an 8 or 8.5 in your white blood cell
coat that's an elevated white blood cell coat in from a functional medicine perspective.
That means quite possibly you're dealing with either a chronic or acute infection that is not
being diagnosed. Now if a person has constant lab values that are outside of that functional range
we'll continue to use white blood cell coat as an example. Let's say they well the last four labs
they did over the last two years they had white blood cell coats in the 8s or 9s or something.
Well that's indicative of maybe a chronic viral infection or something like that that has never
been addressed. Well what's the problem with the chronic viral infection if I don't have any symptoms
from it? Well you could have inflammation from it. You have chronic inflammation. This chronic
low-grade or medium-grade inflammation can cause all sorts of diseases in our body can affect
how our white blood cells are producing. Give me a disease named like this can affect all
the list is endless. So going to a functional medicine doctor getting some labs done even simple labs
that you'd get at a normal physical CBC in a complete metabolic panel put under the scrutiny of
functional medicine perspectives and lab values could give you so very big clues on what else
could be going on that you may want to further investigate. For instance let's use white blood cell
coat again. So let's say the white blood cell coat is elevated and lymphocytes are elevated
given you clues that you could have a chronic viral infection. Well is that possibly causing
something else? So maybe do it antibody test and you see that this person has self-antibodies
to whatever came up positive. Then you do well what else is causing inflammation this body that is
causing self-antibodies. You do a biochemical screen or you do a food antibody test so you could come
up with all sorts of information. And then you could better treat the patient better know what could
be a cause of a problem with the patient and direct care in that way. It's just getting my struggle
with what the practice of medicine has become. Quite often it's practice of functional medicine has become
is labs being done just to achieve a diagnosis instead of labs being done to find now a course
of action to help that person you know come back to normality or to the best level of health
that they have ability to come to. So our labs and tests are not not to be done just so we can
oh you have you know an increase in plasma cells. So we're going to give you this disease name. So
we're going to watch it and we'll finally do something once it turns into multiple myeloma. To me
that's that's not permitted to medicine. All you did is come up with a diagnosis, put a name on it
and again their hands are tied to medical perspective if they're going to use type some sort of
sort of medicine is probably going to be a drug which may alter the lab. It's not actually fixing the
patient. But digging into why that is the case. So how would I keep a pre cancerous condition at
May? I would dig into why. So I would get into some functional medicine tests maybe antibody tests maybe
even start by looking deeper through a functional medicine perspective of the CBC and complete
metabolic panel that you probably had done on a regular basis and start looking for clues and give us
direction what other tests should be the next course of action to get to some core things. The
help with that you could certainly contact our office through our website cutters clinic. You can
schedule a case review with me through our self-schedule page. And you know I don't I'm pretty sure I don't
have any blog posts on this particular condition. But you can find all sorts of blog posts about
cancer that might be might prove to be helpful and different possible causes of cancer that may be
to be helpful because things that cause pre cancerous conditions can be fall into those same categories.
Can you reverse maricose veins? No, not really. There are some things that you can do from a
nutritional standpoint that can cause give a better tone to venous structure. I can't think of
the nutrition of the top of my head because it's been so long since somebody asked me about
maricose veins. But there is some nutritional supplements that we used to use way way back a couple
decades ago. I think it was a standard process supplement that we used to use. Things called
vascular told or something like that. That has helped. Nothing is going to reverse it. But you can
it's again it's a it's a symptom of lots of vascular told. So I think that's available in the product.
They might have changed it by now but we use some nutritional product for people who are prone to
maricose veins. And I do remember that people were helped by it but it's not going to reverse
you know a maricose vein. You see you can see pre maricose veins when you start to see
veins come to the surface. But you have veins you know closely come to the surface and
pass the surface and it's going to be very difficult to really help that.
Well I staff just text me a premier research product called VinaBand, the N-E-N-E-N-E-N-D.
That's a premier research product that is used for that purpose. Thank you for that.
All right. Next question. Are EMFs worse for kids? What can we do to protect our kids?
Well certainly there isn't any studies on this kind of stuff because you can't do studies
of kids. But would you you think that the same EMFs that are affecting us
adults negatively would probably affect a smaller body in a worse case especially in developing
brain developing nervous system would have a greater degree of effect. But there's a limited
amount of things that you could do to prevent EMFs. I always suggest that people
turn off their Wi-Fi at night. I think we discussed a few of these things a few weeks ago.
Somebody asked EMF question. I use a little device called a heat run on my phone. I also use a
phone case that box EMFs and I very rarely put my phone up to my ear. I always put it on
speakerphone. I also use headphones like this. These are air tube headphones. These are the
ones that we sell at our store. It has these little tubes here. So the cell does carry through the
ear of these. So they're basically zero EMF headphones. We sell a lot of these two pairs with kids
because many kids are on you know pads and computers and listening to them. He said
the worst thing you could do is have a Bluetooth device in your ear and you know putting
your cell phones up to your head is not good for you because you have those EMFs coming from you.
So you take a step back and where are we getting EMFs? Well, I'm getting an US from this computer
here but if you had an EMF device, measuring device, you could actually measure how much EMFs
you know that computer produces. I measured and it doesn't produce a lot of EMFs so I'm not
really concerned about that. I actually have a heat run on my computer right here, out of the
corner also. And then you the other source of EMFs are worse is your cell phones. And externally
EMFs from external devices that we're using are EMFs that are you know your electrical box
on the outside of your house, your cell phone towers are the worst culprit. So there's something
besides moving, if you live near cell phone towers, what are you going to do? But certainly there's
some things like using air tube headphones, highly advisable, all like great kids use air tube headphones
when they're when they're listening to things so very helpful.
Question, can it help with prostate E. coli infections? So,
prosthetic infections, whether or what they are,
you again you if you know that it's an E. coli infection that you would you would use
nutrients that would boost your immune system to kill that. If we had a prostate cancer patient
with an E. coli infection as well, then we would run the right machine on E. coli. If you know
what the infection is and if you have a right technology you can get more specific and
more frequencies to run. You don't know what the infection is, then you can run just a viral
program or a bacterial program and you're hoping to be able to hit it. The problem is you're
ready to have it run more time to try to hit that frequency. But definitely immune herbs
definitely with prostate. I would run I would use also nutrients for
prosthetic hypertrophy to decrease inflammation of the prostate as well. We have a product called
prostaclier that has those in it that we use for most of our prostate cancer patients and
prosthetic hypertrophy patients. I would also use burberry with prostate infections and with prostate
cancer that would be a good thing to think about using and anti-inflammatory nutrients. So the
flavonoids like co-committative, bonswellia and stiggy nettle and de-coursited those kind of things.
Next question from the chat, wearable step tracker, smartwatches, body data devices are directly
of the skin, constant EMF exposure. What can I do about that? Those are hard. We are really bombarded
with a lot of EMF sources that our ancestors never had, right? So we wonder why we have
an increase in ADD and ADHD and emotional issues and stress issues and anxiety issues and depression
issues. All these can be tied to EMFs at least in part. So it doesn't mean that we don't have other
things going on, but when you add EMFs, it's just you're filling your bucket with insults that can affect
your health overall. And you just have to start, you know, siphoning through the things that you don't
need your kids to use or yourself to use. Do I really need an Apple watch? No, is this really improving
my life that much? No, it's time to get rid of some of this stuff. What's more important, you know,
that you can track your text messages 24-7 or that you're going to prevent
possible brain cancer or something like that. I don't mean to scare people, but you have to
use wisdom in the risks that you're willing to take being exposed to a greater amount of EMFs.
Also, you'll find that EMFs, people are more sensitive to EMFs if you have,
if you've had any inflammatory damage to your brain. So I think I mentioned this video last time
and it should be something that everybody really should watch. Go to the website, Cutters Clinic,
go to the search button. I have a blog with a video on neuroinflammation search, neuroinflammation.
The neuroinflammation button blog post has a video and it's going to have our video
go through that video. Tap our of your life, but it could save your your family and your friends
life. And the reason is because we can have damage to our brain, causing inflammation in our brain,
causing damage to certain cells in the brain, and worse, you develop antibodies to different
neural tissue. And when that happens, you're going to be more sensitive to infection. You're going to
be more sensitive to EMFs. You're going to be more sensitive to molds. You're going to be more sensitive
to all sorts of things. So if you can understand that pattern, it can be ways to call that pattern out,
the better off you're going to be. Now we have all sorts of different devices that you could use
to decrease EMFs. If you go on our store, you could search EMF devices. We have a little
wristband that you could wear, and a necklace that you could wear that could decrease EMFs.
We have grounding sheets that will help with EMFs. We have static, brand devices that you can plug
into your plugs at home or connect to your electrical box that will decrease dirty electricity
your house. There's a lot of different things that you could do to help with EMFs. But if you don't
cut out a lot of things, it's going to be difficult. And if you don't address the inflammation in the
brain that is causing such ill health with the EMFs, it's going to be difficult. So the more things,
the more ways that you can attack this, the better you're going to be and the better way you're
going to be able to prevent issues. Can you send the link for the product offered? Yeah, maybe Justin
can do that. I don't know. So if you go to our store, go to cuttersclinic.com. And here is
a link that Dustin sent me. Let's see if I can put it in here. You go to our store, though. And
I don't know if that's entered on, but there's a link. Yes, that's the smartwatch link. But if you go to
that, that'll get you into the store. And then that will get you, then you can search for other EMF
products. The heat rod is the little thing that sticks on your phone that helps change the EMFs
from dangerous EMFs to not so dangerous EMFs. You can get a large one for your home. You can get one
for your laptop. You can get it for different devices that you're using. Then we have a whole bunch
of wearable type EMF products. But then go to our cuttersclinic.com website and just search
EMFs. I have a lot of blog posts that will give you some other clues that you don't have to
necessarily spend money and do some things that could help. So I'm not here just to sell you stuff.
I'm here to give you advice that's going to help you with your help. Sometimes it's just stopping
doing some of the things that we're already doing that is going to be your best. That's going to be
your best bet. Here's the link to the other things, just the EMF products. All right. Okay, next
question that was said did remember go to holistichealthour.com after the show and you can see the other
shows. But also that's where you can send it your questions here. So these are some of the other
questions from there. I have stage 4 prostate cancer. What would you recommend?
Well, that's kind of a loaded question because I don't have like a protocol for or stage 4
prostate cancer. So we do cheek swab testing for our cancer patients and then we make recommendations
based on that. And you could have two twin brothers with prostate cancer and their recommendations
could be completely different because everybody's unique. But in general, what should a person do
with prostate cancer? Well, you should do some things that decrease inflammation. But it partly
depends on what else you're doing from a standard of care perspective. If you're doing loop run or
an energy deprivation therapy, everybody do an energy deprivation therapy, which is if you're
going to follow standards of care with prostate cancer, it's just what everybody's going to be in that
category. You should be doing andrographis. Andrographis is an herb and everybody doing energy
deprivation therapy should be own. Also, EGCG, which is the catacid from green T extract.
Everybody that's doing energy deprivation therapy should be on that. Now, historically,
loop run, energy deprivation therapy will reduce a person's PSA. So if you have PSA, if 31 or
12 or 700, it will typically bring that PSA down and it'll give you some comfort that may have my PSA
dropped in half after I started loop run. But there's question of whether it actually decreases the
growth of the cancer product. So if you have to be on loop run, you want it to work as long as
possible. The other issue with loop run has been that it tends to work for a period of time, maybe a
year, maybe two years, maybe four years, and then it just doesn't seem to work. Well, studies have
shown that andrographis and green T extract EGCG increase the time that that that drug will work.
If you're going to be on it, you want it to work as long as possible. Even if you're going to go off
a bit, feed on those two different nutritional products can hold the benefits of that for a longer
period of time. Relatively inexpensive thing to do. If you go to caughtersclinic.com and search
cancer, search prostate cancer, I have lots of articles on prostate cancer with some different
suggestions in it as well. But understand everybody in our clinic is treated as an individual. So I'd
highly recommend you do a case review. We talk about it and we talk about it through possible
checks. Next question. My son has Lyme disease. I believe it's phase three automobile. Okay, so this person
has read my information. So that's good. What should he do? We'll be forward. So I understand
Lyme disease historically has been acute Lyme disease, chronic Lyme disease, and the separated factor
that is the acute Lyme disease is relatively curable through use of antibiotics. So an antibiotic
will kill the Borrelia, Virgidorope, but it's in the blood and in the tissues. But once the bacteria
goes intracellular inside of a cell, antibiotics will kill it. And it can reproduce inside the cell
and it can wait for the opportunity that their bacteria viruses, pathogens, or operatives to
microorganisms. It can wait for the opportunity where it's safe to go back outside the cell,
reproduce even more, bake a person sicker. And then when your immune system kicks up, it goes back
inside the cell, protects itself. There's other avenues that the bacteria has to protect itself,
makes itself part of your Borrelia microbiota, protects itself with a waste layer around it.
There's other protective measurements that Virgidorope has. But if it's moved into that chronic phase
and it's that person has had this chronic Lyme disease for a long enough, as your immune system
continues to try to kill it, it keeps going inside the cell. There can be a time where your
immune system now makes antibodies against your old tissue in the attempt to kill, to sacrifice the
tissue to kill the disease. So now you have antibodies to self tissue. So now you moved into
what I term phase three Lyme. Phase three Lyme, by definition, is that you made antibodies against
your old tissue. So now you're really in an autoimmune disease. Now, once you're in phase three Lyme,
you have antibodies to self tissue. That Borrelia lets pretend that the Borrelia came outside the
cell, your immune system killed it, and now it isn't even present anymore. So you run an IgM
test for Borrelia, and it's negative. You don't have an occurred IgM antibodies,
where you don't have any current infection. You do a CD4 CDA test, you have no current infection.
Your symptoms, though, oh, I'm so sick. How could I not have a current infection? I feel so ill.
I don't feel well. This has been this way for eight years since I got Lyme disease.
How could you say it? I don't have a current. Flare infection. Well, you could be that ill or
worse. With an autoimmune disease, your symptoms are really from the autoimmune disease,
from the destruction of self tissue, and it can be any brand of autoimmune disease. Any named
autoimmune disease, because an autoimmune disease is named after, it's either a systemic autoimmune
disease like Lupus, or it's a tissue-specific autoimmune disease like Hashimoto's, or a tissue
specific to the cerebellum, or tissue-specific to violent sheet cells. So the name of the
autoimmune disease has to do with the antibodies that are being produced, self antivirus, they're reproduced.
So that is what's called phase three autoimmune. How do you question this? How do you treat this
moving forward? Well, you have to make sure you're not taking immune stimulants. But the best way
is to go to our cuttersclinic.com site, excuse me, siteuses, and in 50 bucks, purchase our autoimmune
course. So purchasing our autoimmune course, you know, walk through the steps of really how to treat
any autoimmune disease, whether it's was originated from this Lyme infection, or originated from
mold, or originated from toxins that are environment, or from glyphosate, or pesticides,
and other sorts, or whatever originated from. It doesn't make any difference. Now that you
have self-empty bodies, you have to treat this condition completely different. So that course
will help you understand how to treat it. There's lots of different steps to take. So go through that
course. And if you have questions, if you need support, need help, you could make an appointment
through a case review as well. Okay, that is, I think all our questions for today. So thanks for
being a part of it. We remind you again, go to holistichealthower.com. You'll see all our past episodes
and cuttersclinic.com. And you'll be able to look at our blog posts and search blog posts.
And if you don't think you have a Lyme or an autoimmune disease, jump on one of the courses
that do the course. We also have a sister site that I continue to forget to mention. It's my hope
for Lyme. My hope for Lyme is a bunch of information that affects your injury
and chronic Lyme disease and autoimmune disease, and looking at genetics and such. Thanks for being
a part of our class today. Remember, ask your questions online through the holistichealthower.com.
Have a great day.